hey 42 here Jim Morrison of the 60s rock
group The Doors was the first rock star
to be arrested on stage welcome to RIF
for one day in 1998 Topeka Kansas
renamed itself to - Pikachu - mark
Pokemon - US debut the u.s. bought
Alaska for two cents an acre from Russia
in the 1700s
macaroni was a slang term for a
fashionable man 98% of people in Japan
are cremated California has issued six
driver's licenses to people named Jesus
Christ the top of the Eiffel Tower leans
away from the Sun as the metal facing
the Sun heats up and expands it can move
as much as seven inches in 14th century
England children were baptized in cider
Australian soldiers used a song we're
off to see the Wizard as a marching song
in World War two NASA estimates that the
near-earth asteroid eros contains twenty
billion tons of gold during the 17th
century the Sultan of Turkey ordered his
whole harem of women to be drowned and
replaced with a new one
in ancient Egypt servants were covered
in honey so as to attract flies away
from the Pharaoh Christmas Day is the
number one day for heart attacks
worldwide followed by December the 26th
and then New Year's Day the female lion
does 90% of the hunting for the pride
Icelanders consume more coca-cola per
capita than any other nation thanks for
the view subscribe for more 42